eine brandneue studie unterstützt die
these dass das leben aus dem all auf die
erde gekommen ist denn die spanischen
vorstellen haben in interstellaren
molekülwolken an molekülen nachgewiesen
dass als wichtiger baustein für die zell
bildung gilt eine wirklich spektakuläre
entdeckung denn damit wird auch die
existenz von außerirdischen leben sehr
viel wahrscheinlicher klicks um science
im future bis dreimal pro woche
spannendes heinz venus abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
wie und wann genau ist das erste leben
ja überhaupt sind die ersten lebenden
zellen auf der erde entstanden eine
super spannende frage auf die es trotz
intensiver forschung bis heute keine
eindeutige antwort gibt fest steht
allerdings dass zellen drei grundlegende
bestandteile sogenannte subsysteme
brauchen mit dabei sind unter anderem
biomoleküle wie proteine die die aufgabe
übernehmen den zellstoffwechsel an zu
dreimal so den prozess in dem stoffe in
energie und genau die stoffe umgewandelt
werden die der körper braucht außerdem
auch erb moleküle wie die dna und rna
die genetische informationen beinhalten
und dies auch weitergeben
in der vergangenheit hatten fachleute
hinweise dafür aufgespürt dass diese
beiden der insgesamt drei grundlegenden
subsysteme aus dem all auf die erde
gelangt sein könnten denn nicht nur in
kosmischen molekülwolken sondern auch in
kometen und meteoriten haben
forschungsteams aminosäuren und dna
bausteine genauso wie komplexe
organische moleküle aufgespürt genau das
ist jetzt auch mit dem dritten
bestandteil gelungen den zellen für ihre
entstehung und existenz benötigen
es handelt sich um den stoff woraus die
zellhülle gebildet werden kann
diese schirmt das innere der zelle vor
der außenwelt ab und schützt es vor
umwelteinflüssen heißt also im klartext
auch der entscheidende bestandteil der
ersten zellmembran könnte ursprünglich
aus dem weltall stammen ist unser leben
also außerirdisch und was bedeutet diese
super spannende erkenntnisse für unsere
suche nach außerirdischem leben auf
fremden planeten die antworten auf diese
spannenden fragen gibt es in diesem
in der vergangenheit konnten immer mal
wieder indizien gesammelt werden für die
sogenannte punch perry gemeint ist damit
ein außerirdischer ursprung des
irdischen lebens übersetzt heißt der
begriff so viel wie samen überall der
chemiker svante arrhenius hatte die
sogenannte punch beim hypothese bereits
im jahr 1908 gegründet er hatte damals
postuliert dass sowohl staubkörner als
auch viren und bakterien mit wind und
wetter weit weg von der erde bis ins all
gelangen könnten so schlussfolgerte er
dann daraus dass das auch auf dem
umgekehrten weg passieren könnte
mikroben von fremden planeten könnten
sich auf die reise gemacht haben um die
erde zu besiedeln dafür müssten sie
allerdings nicht nur die lange reise
überleben sondern auch den weg zur erde
finden und dann hier auch noch die
landung überleben war das also der
anfang des lebens auf der erde
auch wenn das auf den ersten blick
abwegig klingt in den vergangenen jahren
wurden tatsächlich viele
widerstandsfähige lebensform entdeckt
die ihn wirklich lebensfeindlichen
bedingungen überleben egal ob in
bitterer kälte großer hitze oder
gesättigter salzsäure und solche
extremen orte auf der erde sind durchaus
vergleichbar mit dem bedingungen auf
fremden himmelskörpern ein experiment an
der iss hat er vor kurzem gezeigt wie
widerstandsfähig mikroorganismen
wirklich sind ganze 5 133 tage lang
hatten diese in einem experiment kasten
an der außenseite der iss verbracht das
ergebnis ist überraschend denn die
organismen trotzdem nicht nur intensive
uv-strahlung sondern auch dem vakuum des
weltraums und extremen
temperaturschwankungen die
verantwortlichen des projekts biology an
mars experiment vom deutschen zentrum
für luft und raumfahrt wollen damit
unter anderem herausfinden aber
organismen von der erde auch auf dem
mars überleben können also ob es auch
auf dem mars leben geben kann können
mikroorganismen den mars bewohnen sind
organismen in der lage die bedingungen
im weltraum zu überleben so dass ein
transport zwischen planeten wie der erde
und dem mars denkbar wäre dass sich die
mikroorganismen in dem stresstest an der
ice es so resistent zeigten hatte selbst
die fachleute überrascht eine abstufung
dieser punch beim hypothese lautet wie
folgt nämlich das zwar nicht das leben
sich aus dem alt stammt aber zumindest
die zutaten für die entstehung von leben
aus dem weltraum kommen keine frage die
grundlegenden bausteine des lebens sind
sogar in großer menge im all vorhanden
die rede ist von sauerstoff stickstoff
wasserstoff und kohlenstoff kometen sind
voll damit
das wissen wir seit etwa 25 jahren 19 86
hatten fachleute den hessischen kometen
genauer untersucht und die analyse des
kometen staubs deckte auf dass ihr sogar
ein einfacher baustein für proteine zu
finden ist glycin organische moleküle
wurden dann auch nochmal zwischen ice
geröll und staub des kometen tschurjumow
gerasimenko nachgewiesen chemische
elemente also die für das leben
entscheiden sind und die scheint es
wirklich überall zu geben sogar in
jungen sternensystemen weit von der erde
entfernt auch dort haben astronomie
teams bereits komplexe organische
moleküle aufgespürt und das nicht zu
knapp
hier scheint so viel mit tools wie er
nicht am start zu sein dass man auf
einem potenziellen planeten sogar einen
ganzen ozean damit füllen könnte
möglicherweise sind diese bausteine des
lebens und ihre vorläufer also vor
langer zeit auf die erde geprallt die
rede ist vom so genannten großen
bombardement von rund vier milliarden
jahren schlugen damals zahlreiche
meteoriten auf der erde ein
und genau das könnte damals den
grundstein für leben gelegt haben denn
auch in verschiedenen proben von
meteoriten konnten bereits aminosäuren
und nuklearen nachgewiesen werden jetzt
ist einem spanischen forschungsteam eine
weitere spektakuläre entdeckung in
diesem zusammenhang gelungen auch der
entscheidende bestandteil der ersten
zellmembran überhaupt könnte
ursprünglich aus dem mal auf die frühe
erde gekommen seien konkret geht es um
ethanol amin das nun erstmals in
interstellaren molekülwolken
nachgewiesen werden konnte es handelt
sich um ein molekül das den
wasserliebenden kopf der doppelmembran
bildet wenn man sich die typische
zellmembran ansieht wird klar dass diese
aus einer doppelschicht von sogenannten
phospholipide besteht außen sitzt ihr
hydrophile also wasser liebender kopf
und innen zwei wasser abweisende also
hydrophobe schwänze aus
kohlenwasserstoff hätten diese
doppelschicht die hülle umgibt die
meisten aller zellen das spanische
forschungsteam hatte eine kalte
molekülwolken er in
visier genommen die sich nahe dem
zentrum unserer galaxie befindet mit
hilfe von radioteleskopen suchten sie
hier im strahlung spektrum nach
signaturen von organischen bestandteilen
der phospholipide membran und dabei
hatten sie tatsächlich erfolgt denn sie
spürten dabei die spektrale signatur von
ethanol amin auf und zwar in der
galaktischen molekülwolken wo das
ethanol amin offensichtlich entstanden
ist dazu schreibt das forschungsteam
dieses molekül bildet den hydrophilen
wasserliebenden kopf des einfachsten und
zweithäufigsten in zellmembran
vorkommenden phospholipide somit steht
nun also fest dass alle drei notwendigen
substanzen der zelle im weltraum zu
finden sind und in der nun analysierten
molekül wolke kommt das ethanol amin
molekülen wirklich nicht zu knapp vor
dass spanischen forschungsteam schätzt
dass etwa ein ethanol amin molekül auf
rund 10 milliarden wasserstoffatome
kommt das klingt zwar auf den ersten
blick erstmal nach ziemlich wenig doch
für ein organisches molekül ist dass
nach angaben der fachleute eine große
menge das forschungsteam geht in der
aktuellen studie davon aus dass das
ethanol amin im weltall entsteht die
wissenschaftlerin wissenschaftler
vermuten dass dies auf der oberfläche
von staubkörnchen passiert und zwar
durch die reaktion verschiedener
kohlenwasserstoffverbindungen auch diese
konnten die fachleute in den spektren
der molekülwolken nachweisen die
entdeckung ist wirklich spektakulär
das ist tatsächlich das erste mal dass
zellmembran bestandteile wie ethanol
amin in kalten molekülwolken aufgespürt
werden konnten so steht nun also fest
dass diese nicht nur auf der erde oder
im inneren seltener meteoriten
existieren schon lange hatten fachleute
weltweit spekuliert dass die kosmischen
wolken die große teile des
interstellaren raums ausfüllen
organische moleküle enthalten
die aktuelle entdeckung bestätigt dies
jetzt dazu schreibt das forschungsteam
diese entdeckung ergänzt die früheren
nachweise von bono kreativen und
aminosäuren im interstellaren medium
damit könnten bausteine aller drei
subsysteme des lebens durch
interstellare chemie synthetisiert
worden seien und damit auch teil des
materials gewesen sein aus dem sich 1
das sonnensystem bildet klar ist hierbei
geht es längst nicht nur mehr um die
entstehung des lebens auf der erde
sondern
zitat auch auf anderen habitablen
planeten und monden überall im universum
wie das forschungsteam schreibt denn die
bausteine für leben existieren sicher
nicht nur im interstellaren medium
sondern sind auch auf anderen planeten
und planetensystemen zu finden und das
hat genau eine folge die entstehung von
leben auf anderen planeten und fremden
himmelskörper wird damit immer
wahrscheinlicher und das würde dann auch
für den zwergplaneten pluto gelten leben
auf pluto möglich new horizons aufnahmen
lassen auf wasser schließen anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren den roten knopf
findet ihr unter jedem video einfach
anlegen ist vollkommen gratis also bis
dann bleibt dran